so
validation and cross-validation we
actually talked about in quite a bit of
detail in the section along with the
bootstrap so i won't cover it in much
detail now just to remind you so the
basic idea is now or the basic problem
right we have a sequence of models like
for example from subset regression
forward step bys or backward stepwise
each one with a model size k and we want
to choose the best model size
we just talked about some methods based
on adjusting the rss
cp
aic and bic
validation cross validation rather than
make an adjustment they're more direct
so just remind you what the idea of
validation is
we divide the data up into two parts a
training set and a validation part
so let's say let's just draw that so
here's my training part
at random
maybe i'm going to choose say a half or
three quarters to my training set and
the balance to be the validation set
and then the basic ideas are going to
fit the models of various sizes of
various k
for example if it's fourth stepwise i'm
going to choose the
i'm going to find that the best model of
each so the best the forward stepwise
model of each size k on my training set
and then evaluate its error on the
validation part
and the validation error as a function
of k will be my what will be what i use
to to estimate prediction error and to
choose the model size so this is
validation and cross validation is much
like that except
it's sort of a k k act play right so
it's full cross validation i'll divide
the data up into five parts two
three four five and then
at each stage of the play
four of the parts our training sets
are the training set
so let's say these first four parts of
the training set
and this last guy is the validation in
this
phase
so i will fit my
models of of all size k to these four
parts of the data the training set
and evaluate the error on the validation
part
and i'll do that in turn for the five
different possibilities where at each
stage one of the pieces is the
validation and the other four pieces of
the training and then we'll summarize
the results together to get an idea of
the error as a function of k
that's called a cross validation error
estimate and then we'll find the minimum
of that curve
so again i said that quickly because
we've gone over that in detail
in the previous section of the course
so here i have
i have said this again in words
on the second bullet item
so either using validation or cross
validation we'll get an
idea of the error for each model size k
and then select the k that gives us the
lowest test error over the the
validation part of the process
and
this is actually a very attractive
approach and we've said this already but
it's good to say it again compared to
the other method we talked about the
advantage there's a number of advantages
the one big advantage it doesn't require
an estimate of sigma squared
you might think that's a small advantage
but it's actually quite quite important
because if p is bigger than n as it is
quite often in data that we see these
days
to get an idea of the an estimate of
sigma squared is very difficult we can't
fit a full model because the full model
will totally saturate and give an error
of zero
so we need we have to pick some kind of
a smaller model but we can it's quite
arbitrary the model we pick and it's
hard to know
we'd like to fit a model that has
all the good variables and leaves out
the noise variables but we don't know of
course what's the signal what's the
noise if we did know that we wouldn't
even have to do it we wouldn't have to
think of these models so it's
getting any idea of sigma squared it
seems like it may be a trivial matter
but it's actually very challenging for
models
uh with for situations with with large
numbers of features so and that's
actually challenging to the point where
like it's an open area in statistical
research so like i you know i'm an
associate editor for a journal and we we
get submissions from like statisticians
at top tier universities
who are coming up with ways to estimate
sigma squared so you know maybe in ten
years uh this will no longer be a
challenge but right now it's really hard
to do and that's actually one of the
reasons it's so much fun to be a
statistician because we get new kinds of
data much for example a high dimensional
data with large numbers of variables and
presents challenges to the
to
things which are simple in with small
numbers of variables now become very
challenging but very important so
the technology and the the
the
kinds of data that we see
bring
bring new challenges to our field every
day
so
cross-validation
helps to solve that problem by avoiding
an estimate of sigma squared we don't
need to plug in sigma squared anywhere
the other point is you don't need to
know d remember these
previous formulas for example the
adjusted r squared had a d in it and cp
and aic and bic have all had the number
of parameters
well again that might seem sort of a
silly thing of course you know the
number of parameters in your model well
that's true when your model is
is a linear model and you pick you're
choosing predictors
as coefficients
but for methods like ridge regression
and lasso which are shrinkage methods
we'll talk about next
it's not at all clear what d is and it's
actually it's another whole area of
research figuring out
what is meant by d the number of
parameters in a model which is not fit
by least squares
so again cross validation
finesses that problem by not requiring a
you you to plug in a value for d so d
and sigma squared are both challenges
and cross validation
relieves the worry of having to come up
with good estimates of those
so i've said all these things
so let's see what it looks like in the
credit data example
so
again the number of predictors here we
apply to the square root of bic just to
make it comparable to the other two
estimates the validation set error and
the cross validation error so here we
did actually validation set was three
quarters one quarter
so three quarters of the data was
randomly chosen to be the training set
one quarter is the validation set and we
see the error
tracked as a function of the number of
predictors we've marked the minimum
and here it's about six predictors
cross-validation i think this was do i
say here five
a ten-fold cross-validation we like 5 or
10 full cross validation in general
they're good good values
it's producing about the same model size
6 as the minimum again the curve is very
flat it's hard to see here it's rising
very slightly to the right
but there's not much to choose between
say four and ten four and eleven
predictors right they're giving you
basically the same error
bic as as often the case remember we
said compared to aic it
it imposes a stronger penalty on the
on the model size it tends to produce
models which are a little bit smaller
and they did so here about here it's
about four but again the curve is so
flat there's not much we can really say
about these
models between three and eleven
predictors
and actually i mentioned the bottom here
the one standard error rule we talked
about this a bit in the cross validation
section let me just remind you what that
is
the one standard error rule says well
we're not going to pick the actual
minimum of the curve but we'll
acknowledge the fact that the curves
have variation because they're actually
they're they're random variables just
like the data are the functions of the
data
so the one standard error rule let's
draw it
just in
pictures here so let's suppose we have a
one of these curves in the minimum
here's the actual the actual minimum the
standard error of the curve which we
didn't indicate in these examples but we
should have we can get well the cross
validation just an average over the k
folds
so the standard error of that mean of
k
things like kx 10 the standard error of
those 10 numbers gives us the standard
error of this curve so we could draw the
standard error plus or minus one
standard errors from the minimum
so the one standard error rule says
remember this is the number of
predictors along the horizontal axis
it says don't choose the minimum
but
take the simplest model that comes with
one standard error of the minimum so
that would be we'd come across to here
and we choose this model
okay
so the idea being well if these models
are within one standard error of each
other we really can't
tell them apart on the basis of the data
because they're
the error is almost the same so all
those equal we'd rather have a simpler
model
so that's why we've moved
to a model to the left here which has
fewer predictors and its error is no
more than one standard error away from
the
the error of the
of the best model so the one standard
error rule which is is pretty popular
now it's not used at the model with the
absolute minimum but use a simpler model
that comes within one standard deviation
of the of the minimum
okay
so the rationale for this again i've
said it is that
if the models are within one standard
error of each other let's choose the
simplest one
because it's easier to interpret